The secret to start learning a language
and keep learning it is simple: connect
with it emotionally. Every day, when I sit
down and I learn, I remind myself of WHY
I am learning.
Reminding myself of the reasons why is
the most important thing you can do to
keep going. I use a simple visualization
technique to emotionally connect with a
language which I call S.E.E. "S" stands for
state. Your state of mind has a huge
impact on how you learn and how you see
yourself in the now and in the future. "E"
stands for emotion.There is no learning
no plan, and no life without emotion. To
make things strong and solid, add
emotions to whatever you do. "E" stands
for "eye", in this case the eye of your mind.
With this eye you can see things what
your physical eyes still cannot see. See
beyond to make your future real, make
your future a reality. I'm in Budapest
I'm standing on one side of the Margaret
bridge. On the one side of the river, in
Pest,
I see the massive Hungarian Parliament in
all its illuminated glory, and on the
other side I see the green hills of
Buda, now cloaked in the darkness of
night. All at once, I'm overcome with a
wave of nostalgia. For a moment that
seems like an eternity, I am caught
between the past and the future, and that
reminds me of when I was here for the
first time some 10 years ago. And then my friend Edit comes. She smiles at me. We
decide to head over to a restaurant, we
order Hungarian food and we talk about
everything: about Hungary, Budapest, Hungarian food, Hungarian wine, about history,
about the differences between Hungary
and Italy. And the night goes on..